hang out during oktoberfest by some
amazing amazing coincidence of timing
every single sales organization across
all of Google has to have an off-site
meeting in the Munich office this week
who knows i don't know it the the stars
must have come into alignment but
anyways those of us who aren't in sales
are here to talk to you about anything
and everything having to do with android
development so I'm Sparky coming to you
from Munich Germany and I'm also joined
by Nick and rich in London UK so hello
everyone welcome it's Wednesday
afternoon let's talk android yeah it's
nick Gretchen matters up man what's
happened to Matt dry damn it as always
hey how you do and he seems to also be
at Al's house at the same time yeah you
get everyone on set between us I was
held max beamed up to the mothership for
the week so he's it in Mountain View so
fast asleep right now unless he joins a
hangout that's a poor excuse but anyway
he could be woken up uh so as usual with
these we won't be talking about anything
as previously not been announced but
something has recently been announced
that we can talk about ah what time does
that go live that blog post anything
yeah midday today a couple of hours ago
we announced at the google play store
has now had 25 billion invading son de
the google play said 25 billion know and
i do it again so we could sink right
installs and as part of that we're
having a promotion when 25 apps games
books movies if those verticals launch
in your country yet keep an eye on the
Google Play Store and later today we'll
be announcing which apps and gonna be on
sale and books and other content as well
so keep an eye out for some celebrations
and some bargains should be live so oh
my goodness I can feel the numbers
melting off my credit card already he
had her when we had our 10 billion
promotion last fall when was it November
I i bought i think 56 apps during that
promotion I don't know what I'm gonna do
this time it's been five dollars 60
perhaps jeez do you remember what they
all were though I was in an airport with
someone using flight track and I go wow
that's amazing i should get that and
they check the play store it turns out
that they bought it during the 10 10 10
promotion and i remember that they
bought it so they were quite happy to
see it as a purchased application yeah
yeah i'll also be buying i think every
single application during the next
promotion which is really right this way
i have a flight track but honestly I've
gotten a lot more you sort of flight
control okay yeah I think that says more
about you travel habits and then it is
ok I must apologize for the quality of
our video today we seem quite pixelated
will try and sit real still dum dee dum
de dum I'll be back in an hour okay
Sparky's got control right before we hit
the robots I jumped up girls purse Nick
now me yeah right after we I hit the
brook us but no jumped up my seat and
ash my Nexus 7 no longer responding
that's glass sticking out no no it's
just the way you want to get some more
credit for the play store sale every
single out like four times over
excellent so out and I've been seeing
some post for you on google+ about AOSP
top TV what is that and yeah it's a
little project that started at the fest
hackathon about week and a half ago I'm
taking the android open source project
which is basically the way that you guys
make Android available to the rest of
the world and making it more suitable
for a TV and one of the first steps was
being able to use another device to
controller so what I've shown is Galaxy
Nexus and the nexus s both being the
main gaming machine both running quake
in sitting back with an Xperia Play and
using that as the controller nice so
you're connecting up the standard
Android like phone device using and then
using HDMI out apply this content on TV
yep that's exactly that's all I'm doing
on that side android device to control
it yeah so you can set your phone in
front of your TV and connect up and then
it uses Bluetooth to connect to anybody
else's phone he wants to sit around and
play games nice you've got no load
android device with a shoe out
in a drawer somewhere why not turn your
TV into a connected TV yeah yeah
absolutely gotta wear my neck success is
probably gonna live for a while now hmm
to the nexus s sh t Miami know how you
doing that an excess in haste my dear
I'm there was a I thought there was a
connector you could get for it I've got
one for the Galaxy Nexus which is the
MHL connector but I thought that was
backwards compatible with a nexus s I
don't think the Nexus S at it cuz my
sleep or filling stations we have these
hack together Frank and photos with them
things solid into the back of them ah
looks like I'm gonna have to go device
hunting in my box for another one that's
got HDMI out maybe my optimus to actual
fine see the light of day again yeah I
think we got a couple of tablets that
might be a good candidate for hooking up
to a TV recompiling fun Nick yeah that's
right and what I'm doing is the nexus s
and the galaxy nexus of both supported
in the Android I'm source project but so
displayed the Wi-Fi zoom and my dro have
released a bootloader unlocker that will
work even with the UK Wi-Fi one so i
should be able to get it running on that
and given the amount of changes that
I've made they're quite minimal I could
probably also graft it onto cyanogenmod
earn that opens up a whole world of
extra devices it could run on nice
excellent excellent excellent work thank
you
I'm full strong about myself so who is
this is joining us who have just muted
paul hansen has joined us in to hang out
i seen drica did paul did you warn us
ahead of time that you were gonna ask us
a stumper question yes where's don't
enough go ahead hey I'll meet impressed
did you said yes I heard him say yes yes
I heard that too question pool let me
see if I can find in the moderator I
think it's this one well this is this
asset is coming from Pablo in central
England but I thought this was Paul
question why I i we read smart cards
phipps with fixed power-on self-test
time most need a second to complete
android default NFC I so dep time out of
0 point three seconds is too short
gingerbread we can override this 22
seconds works well ICS and jelly bean
does not work any ideas if I had any
expertise in NFC i would share it with
you I'm going to get Trevor on the line
you need to ask this in the amount of
your office hours in eight hours time
it's Trevor did a whole lot of Weber
than Sen wrote a superb at the scanning
Mobile World Congress badges
interestingly I want on vacation
recently and they gave us a NFC room key
I did not do as Trevor did I didn't
reverse engineer at her turned my phone
into a virtual room key or anything but
it was it was pretty cool to be able to
read the data out of my room keys in my
phone I gave me a really warm fuzzy
feeling about the security of this hotel
ok hey me can hear me 80 on this Maria I
like what my son through ok yeah yes so
it's just that NFC question was a timer
issue between the different os's of
Android with Gingerbread we were able to
override it but the way it launches in
ice cream sandwich is it decides to
timeout before it informs the
application so the point three seconds
will not allow the certain types of card
to be read and pass three so I just want
to do this on Stack Overflow they said
that you can't adjust this but I just
wanted also for forward warning for
future versions of Android whether we
can increase the default to one second
ah yeah so that sounds like a pretty
specific question which I'm not really
familiar with like have you gone
spelunking into the code base and found
out where that and bigoted what she can
do is on the iso dep you can call dot
set timeout and you can change that to
any value but the problem is is the way
that the NFC lifecycle is in ice cream
sandwich is it never gets called because
it doesn't launch the app so I can't
when you set it on targets is in the
documentation that also seems you close
the target it reverts back to this
default time out of point three seconds
but if you set it you have to be in the
code to set it so you have to have
launched the application so that's the
problem the problem is the Android won't
launch the application for those kind of
cards the old cards will work the
problem is all of the new cards are
going beyond the 1 2.3 seconds so I
can't change the cards are you training
into your app you doing it on and let
disability be on technical is both and
even on technical it isn't long enough
you basically I've got the code here
I've look I'm doing
so do the resolve intent on action
discovered or on actiontec discovered or
on action tag discovered it goes cause
the same function then I'll get the tag
I'll get the tag object and then I
immediately tried to call the set
timeout put in Ice Cream Sandwich I
can't even debark on even step into that
code at all but on gingerbread it will
get there allow me to set the timeout
and the which will allow the rest of the
process to continue one of that's due to
the lack of higher level API is like
Android Beam don't know but it's quite
interesting that gingerbread lets you do
that the problem is they've been demoing
on some of the phones and obviously you
want to try the galaxy know and the s3
and things like that and I keep having
to dig out an old car to try get to work
so does it work if you pre launch the
application and I doesn't appear to work
if you pre launch or if it's launched
from the tag event I tried some tricks
like making a static tag object and
trying to hang on to the reference to
set the timeout from a previous time but
I couldn't seem to get that to work
either and it sounds a bit bit like a
bad piece of engineering as well you
know well there's there's there's the
difference between just make this work
and go to production with it yeah least
I hope there's a difference so failing
there's the furling a short term
solution I'd like to make it I'd like
you to be considered for a future
android version I could print out the
default log well the right way time out
the right way to voice that feature of
with would be to file a feature requests
on on AOSP okay so if you go to fever
Android a pawn shop for bugs there's a
section air about and filing bugs one of
the types of bug you filed a feature
request okay nice to report that to
lesson you'll get logged in catalogs and
prioritize net means let's say on yes
because i think this problem will affect
the obviously the u.s. primary the u.s.
cards will be like that and increasingly
in europe so it will
you kind of stop business card thanks
I've never heard of this this is a card
with security on it so it's basically
what happens is when the NSE event
happens it's powering up a dinner
self-check so these are I think it's
fragmented at the moment but i think
it's increasing this type of cards
increasing in use and was no way around
we can't sort of change what cars people
are using sort of across the country
sort of thing so it's not interesting
canoe and sakura standard sorry yeah
issue is it as a post on step over
friend send us a link sorry you write up
this issue he posted it to step over
already yes I would got it on stuff edit
stack overflow there's a guy called NFC
NEC guys quite good and those his stuff
because he works with Android and he's
them had a few goes but he said he said
he can't do anything about see an Ice
Cream Sandwich anything it's a link to
it and yes audio yeah your way to paste
in this window here no exalt go away at
the end this hangout can you post it as
a comment on the cheapest event but the
cheapest okay you know no problem and
you can also posted in the chat I
usually copy those and save them to a
text file at the end all right i'll do
both i'll have a look at that but yeah i
mean it the very least it'd be good if
the default is at least one second so it
work with all kinds of cards because
it'll be an issue in them in the US as
well but yeah I didn't let anyone's got
any short-term ideas I don't think it's
out easy to to sort out cuz I've tried a
bit of everything from stack overflow so
it's been so I've been looking at for a
few weeks I'm not sure if anyone's
actually dug into the source code there
but there is a service which controls
the time out for reading tags and things
like that okay if you can put pacer
linkers rich and Nick asked for yeah
I'll have a dig into that and see if
there's a way to set it from a third
party application that would be
brilliant because there seemed to be
methods to set it but i'm not sure what
restrictions are placed on those methods
whether they're exposed third party apps
or not so it may or may not work yes
because because sort of putting our
custom OS is only good for internal but
as soon as we go out to other people we
want better did up but yeah if the
can override something I'd be fantastic
to look at oh
cool thank you very much we have a start
to have a look at the moderator for this
week then well we've got a couple of
people on the Hangout we've got
Sebastian is that right and and Richard
Thompson do you guys have anything you
want to talk about before we go into the
moderator content which it is liking yes
please I'll attended but both typing
while they're typing maybe we can get a
moderator question um we can teach you
get a Gangnam style dance all the way'
see how are you guys doing so crystal in
estonia wants to know he says i have a
web based game that includes purchase of
digital goods do I still have to use
Google Wallet for purchases sorry yes we
understand that that Estonia is not a
Google Wallet merchant country but that
still doesn't excuse you from the terms
of the Play Store which is if you're
hosted in play store you need to use
google wallet is your payment method
mechanism there is the the
multi-platform work around that we've
discussed before where if you have a
piece of digital content that's equally
usable in several different places like
say in you know the Amazon music player
the apple itunes player google music and
and the same digital purchase confers
rights to all these different platforms
then we don't require you to use wallet
but otherwise basically our store our
payment method sorry yeah we have come
this before there are some applications
that are a great area in this and they
looked at by the editorial team or the
abuse team whatever whichever one it is
and they make a decision on it but
generally yeah just stick to the
guidelines unfortunately if while it's
not in your country and it's not
possible to use the in-app payment or
the paid app system you could choose to
partner with the publisher and another
tree will do something else which
enables you to have an account from
another country we regret that we can't
be everywhere at once you know we're
working on it I also like to point out
we are not forcing you to distribute
your app through google play you can
choose another market if that's the way
you want to monetize your app we have an
open ecosystem and you're free to do
that oh I know I know that's not the
ideal answer but the idea dance would be
we supported merchants of all countries
but Google what it is robbing up okay so
we have a question in sidebar from
Richard Thompson so Richard and
correctly point out at the Android
design guidelines recommend a 16 dip
margin on the sides of your screen but
he asks what is the recommended padding
to the top and bottom as demonstrated
four-inch thank you that is often
bombers and so I would probably say two
ends on what you're showing is this
commonly the answer so if you're showing
like a listview for example I think that
same screen on an on metrics and rhythms
will recommend you know the recommended
light height with eight tips above and
below so you fall into the standard 48
dip ribbon so that's you know one thing
if you're not kind of going for content
straight away you might want to echo the
16 dip margin you have on the left and
right to to give it an even keel it kind
of really depends on your content so I
would say yeah personally I'd say if
you've got an action bar at the top and
the top is well-defined you have zero
margin above that and the list is going
to drill straight through the bottom of
the screen if you have any or whatever
it is the content will go straight
through the bottom of the screen so if
you hadn't imagined there it might be
slightly confusing to the user that the
the UI is ending before yes list item
itself includes planning within it you'd
won it hard against if you had a button
is the first thing under the action bar
you wouldn't put that hard up against
the action bar I'd probably go the 16
dips yeah I heard that you want it's
nice to have a consistent well give your
design on it certainly was an
sebastian's junket right Richard says
thank you and spastic says I live in
Venezuela and we have had restrictions
to use foreign currencies
we we have hard restrictions to 12 miles
is there a possibility for us to sell
our apps in local currency in play would
we go in and create a local market ah
sort of just the dust that sort of
what's do we we kind of just
talked through that one yeah as far as
going to be a merchant country either so
you can't sell your apps in Google Play
until we support Venezuela as a merchant
country unless that's not the case and
it is and it's already is not better yes
you can create a local market you
potentially sell it through the operator
stores with there are any or you can put
it on google play and monetize through
different means maybe advertising but
the monetization options direct
monetization on google play's and open
to non merchant countries i think one of
the other problems is Venezuela is
actually listed as a Play Store able to
sell paid applications I don't know if
he's having issues with the fact of
foreign exchange rules in Venezuela and
selling in things like US dollars and
stuff like that may cause legal problems
as a only what we read around that is
for the developer just to select
Venezuela is the only country they sell
to as well yeah Venezuela resisted is a
merchant country and you have it
restrictions on selling foreign
countries done yet you have to also a
babe ID or country's laws and
regulations now or an allover typing ah
we have another person to join us whose
name I cannot pronounce but he's got a
feather in his hair I love to them hello
new Cologne and an army hey me fly yeah
you have any questions that would be a
good time to ask them in the meantime
thanks for posting those links out and
Paul Paul just posted a link to the
stack overflow issue with NFC and how to
put it the supported countries thing
yeah
right we have any more moderate
questions if they do live in the round
two on the who do I'm trying to get back
to you guys I've sort of lost your
window you must have not taken there you
are there you are this is the link to
the to the merchant countries of which I
regret to say Venezuela is not one and
and for the record neither is India is
the link that you posted out the link of
countries that you can sell a plane as
opposed to the links you can sell them
from its where you can sell them from
it's the google play for developers
supported locations for distributing
applications that's where you can sell
them to not something from what the last
section says the developers in these
locations may also sell paid
applications to users in the rest of the
world ah look at the two links and I
can't read on the screen from that
window up there but um I know there's
there's certainly three different
sections in that document if it's one
with about 31 countries then that's the
merchant list if it's wrong with a
hundreds of 30 countries and that's that
countries you can sell apps into and
then everything else is look it looks
like the 31 list but if you have alert
and collective night be cool yeah sure
not that I like a new one Jonah run to
the next question Sparky in the word ah
we looked at that one uh Johan pilgrim
in the Netherlands says let's say I add
some state to an activity via Nintendo
extra I'm activity is destroyed when the
user navigates back to my activity can I
depend on the framework to reuse the
original intent to start it IE will the
intent extra be there this is too
elaborate can I depend on the original
intent extra or do I need to save it
using on statements on save instance
state or something like that which of
course with me in trying to retrieve it
from the extra etc so and he can't be in
the Hangout so we're free to talk about
it without and we can say nasty things
of what I mean he'll never know until he
watches the replay so my answer to him
at least the moderator was it depends on
how the activity was was exited if it if
it just got pushed down the stack by
some other activities being open on top
of it then I think the original intent
is still there but if the user presses
the back button then the activity is
destroyed and I think it's going to take
a whole new intent to get it back again
is that some right you guys yeah if you
want things to be like saved and passed
then when you recreated then use on
savings and state that suppose for an
orientation change will also kill off
any extras won't it yep tear it all down
I'm creating it Oh Kailyn few new
joiners we've got Jeff is joining us and
what's just certain folks like Jeff
enjoyed that would be amazing Oh Jeff us
in the sidebar there can we add the
information about padding and I don't
know because it's really it depends
answer so the one that's fixes the side
padding with protective design
guidelines with the top and bottom is
yes I would it seems to me like we have
kind of set a precedent of having an
eight dip design rule so you should you
know the very least try to separate
things way it dips that that kind of
feels right to me um really takes me
back to when we were designing computer
chips you know you get your your your
minimum feature size and everything's
and multiples of that I think our
minimum feature size here is eight dibs
at least I can't wait I just can't wait
for the future when we start using lsi
design tools for writing software oh the
pool so else in this life I question
yeah I've got I've got a question about
the wallet just why people talking just
thought is there a provision for like
storing tickets on the wallets or how
does that bit work if you if you want to
sell third party tickets or something no
it's just purely payments is it as I
understand that and it's only payments
from approved card approvers it's not
sort of payments anyone can add anything
to okay so if you're if you're making a
payment to say sell a ticket to an event
use up to you what you do with that
ticket how you do it it's not tight as
wallet in any way right okay so it's no
solve encryption alors thent occation or
need need in three persons purchase at
that stage tie to that so okay so
completely open thank you any other
questions for the room while she would
crack on with the moderator I say that
we've been joined by jitendra jitendra
have anything to ask no android client
for the Google+ video hangout all right
yeah this is I mean it's not a purely
hangout right it's it's this this google
live it's an add a YouTube live stream
um I thought I thought I heard from one
of our developers that he could see it
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's fine there's
nothing for us to do yeah I've had it
running I had some issues with sound but
that's probably more my network
bandwidth than anything else hey it's
just YouTube is divine right you just
soak them you two can go to the life
section and we should be right right
there that's at and there's also you can
join in with the hangouts on air from
the Google+ client on Android okay it
should work on hang on handsets so yeah
jeff says it works on his tablet but not
on his HTC evo 4g so i guess it's going
to depend upon which version of the
YouTube application you're running on
supported video format so it's all hung
before basically YouTube and spits out
the live stream in a variety of formats
and you can take a little while before
it spits out the mobile-friendly one
which is why we're trying to start a
hangout a little bit before we're
actually going to start broadcasting and
then I 10 online so it might just be a
case of checking back a little bit later
sorry about that sometimes insanity
works do you think it's just it's just a
Singh pipeline delay them so that's one
of the potential issues that you can
give they answer the other females
people could be if you had an older
version some reason then you might not
support the hangouts on air ago they
check to make sure you got the latest
version generally we don't follow the
youtube comment to Jeff library check
them out afterwards we usually follow
the comments on the Google+ posting for
this live event and also won the
moderator yeah youtube comments aren't
quite the same quality any places people
face comments and YouTube live seems to
be the lowest like senior high icons I
could see having somebody follow the
youtube comment if we were able to
devote you know to devote a person who
monitor the streams as opposed to having
everybody on camera all the time I I
don't know if our viewers are aware of
this but when you look at the hangouts
that are run by the California team
they've got so many guys over there that
they've always got one or two people
off-camera producing the show well you
get here in emea is the entire android
dev rel organization on camera talking
to you live hello def makes a good point
though like n so how is he asked
questions you have to kind of jump
upstream go into the G+ clients or
something place which is a fair point so
maybe we should start wandering than
somehow so far there is only one
question in the YouTube stream and it's
from yeah Jeff could you I thought hey
doll hello sorry for the lady join me
forgot to change time zones here we are
living their visas nice ah pretty
switched we can't be far i'm switching
about yeah squares up all the calendars
okay moderator i was just looking at
that moderator another couple of
questions came trickling in while we
were talking let's scroll down the right
one any idea if it's possible to change
the animation of you
to something other than slide ie an app
drawer style overlapping transition
mmhmm yeah I mean view paging is
applesauce if you've downloaded the come
support library it's the source is even
lying on your computer right now I'm the
Android SDK extras compatibility google
something you'll see it down there
support source uh and you can put those
words in any order and it will just be
there man she's magic I've gone through
the sauce myself and played around with
it yeah you can it's incredibly readable
actually I think I highly recommend
everyone to take a look at the source of
view pager because it's a very very
readable very well structured and you
can learn a lot and say good job Adam
pal good job Adam Powell yeah so you can
look into there and play around with it
change the way it worked change
animations if you really want to it's
already got the finger tracking built in
which is quite nice and so on yes you
can yes I would say you'd probably want
to extend the viewpager and change it
rather than I don't think there's a
setting to change animation on the VIP
area for you looking at creating your
own widget but yeah i'd say like
ninety-five percent of the work is done
for you already if you start from the
imagine you could call it drawer slide a
pager or something for us later people
or if you want to look like the apps
tray why don't you look at the source
code of the apps tray which is in
longitude login excellent what's the
thing on the right yet launched it is it
still cool fun life again Thank You Alan
for the question some of our more
popular contributors it is still on to
take Cheers I was looking back at that
link as well out and that is the list of
countries that you can sell out into the
bit where it says developers in these
countries may also sell to other
countries that in these countries as a
link when you click on that you see the
30 countries are right for ocean all
that leaflets below that Fenton yeah and
then you gets them which doesn't have
Venezuela in it it's good I proposed it
thanks for checking out Richard what's
the hundred and thirty i'm looking into
implementing the android backup service
in my app says we yeah right what people
should look into doing their love that
service but i can't find any examples on
how to use super like databases
uh is there a sequel helper for the
backup service I kind of thought the
point of the backup service was for
restoring devices his channel I wouldn't
you want to do it off device so the
other backup service yes I think what he
wants to do is does he want to back up
to a secret like database for backup
sequel like database to the cloud oh my
gosh I interpreted as the backup and
restore service yeah the thing because
dollars your shared preferences and
whatnot when you log into a new device
and some fine examples on how to use it
with secret life databases and that is
it's a there is a confusion that he may
be talking about using the backup
service to back up to a database we use
the backup service to back up to
supervise database to the cloud because
but I think he means the cloud cell is
not the v no but the examples we have a
file backup and shared preferences back
apartment are back actually backs up to
the farm of it STK maybe he wants to
make up to us as it was though it be
silicon yes comprising the secret
database with the cloud isn't part of
the thing the issue that when you
synchronize a backup you've got no
guarantee it's going to a sequel
database so that there's no ability to
translate a sequel database on the
device directly to a sequel database in
the cloud because you don't know that's
where it's being stored so it's going to
need to write some kind of translator
that puts it in the appropriate format
anyway so and doing a generic one of
those is going to be difficult because
you need to make assumptions about the
database you can blob it if you just
want this app and overwrite the database
on restore which is financed equal that
databases you can just back up the Bob
at the sequel like database proud and
then when you restore just if it's got
out just yet time to grab the latest one
atmosphere
I wanted me to talk to Drew um yeah a
nicer way of doing it would be to
synchronize the database but then you've
got to ya do exactly that figure out
what date has changed when it changed
and do the synchronizations more like
gmail does it when you hit the refresh
you see something else too deleting some
appearing like I think such as mute
everyone else as long as I think there's
a muting war going on um but in terms of
a guy's looking for example code for it
maybe we should have one here slightly
tricky I'm also curious about what data
you turn it back up if it's like a large
sequel database I'm not sure that's
exactly what it's intended for I think
it's more for like backing up in
configurations and settings and so on so
forth such that if you accidentally step
on your device and smash the screen a
new one and when you log in here are
things the same as you live in there's a
stack overflow question which shows a
very quick way of backing up a whole
sequel I'd database as a blob or stick a
link to that in the client for this post
that's definitely gonna be the easiest
way anything else when you've almost
typically air preferences back up how
much was that little you a good idea of
what if you want to do the
synchronization as well of each
individual's database item okay let's
see we've got a couple new people in the
Hangout we got cut Almeida's joined and
Jordi is drying so welcome to hang out
guys if you have anything that you want
to discuss regarding android application
development please let us know does
anyone know how to skip to a particular
point in a YouTube video the mobile app
whoo I understand you can embed that in
the URL
note you can do it and I think that
point they are wary symbolizes any
anything which is broadcast on youtube
live infrastructure doesn't let you use
the scrubber little progress bar to skip
ahead and especially to actually
watching the live broadcasting undo that
absolutely I want the future damn it no
you guys get back to like no you can't
lowest revive restart right there's a
limitation of the YouTube live mobile
moment it's just a stream Mitra but I
think after a period of time once
YouTube processes it then it becomes a
regular video that the recording after
this will become a regular YouTube video
at some point you'll be able to scrub
back and forth not for those nails yeah
it's definitely a while after because
I've checked sony now or two after and
it still just has the the play through
the entire life show you as an option
but if you go to the web version then
you can scrub backwards and forwards i
was trying to continue to watch some
broadcasts on my phone but I couldn't
skip to where I got on my pc yeah that's
a current limitation of the watching a
YouTube live video on the YouTube mobile
plan you have to go back to you may be
able to get away with it if you've got
flash installed you might go to go to
the web browser and go through that and
not let you tube launch it may be able
to go forward to the right point in the
video through the browser if I don't you
get add that I mean sorta like own sink
where you can where you can bookmark
something and your pc and have it show
up on your mac or a google maps where
you can star something and one have it
show on the other you need to have that
with YouTube to just push my video from
my phone straight to my to my desktop
and keep watching don't want sperry well
with the works confined to tablets
within right it has 33 l that x is q you
can just bring it tablet TV TV tablet up
and down the next six position and I'm
it is repost this question as gonna say
there's one in the sidebar you're really
average as long well Google App Engine
be a good option instead of Amazon Web
Services a good question yes okay
there's more for writing reading data
with low latency when we have thousands
of users performing read/write to server
the issue is when data is shredded and
the response time needs to be very small
well Google App Engine handle something
like Instagram do we have any use cases
similar to it
we've got memcache right so so your your
date your default method of saving
things in App Engine is is data store
and which of course is you know shared
by all the different front ends that are
accessed all the different front-end
instances that are serving your app and
then you've got memcache which keeps
things in memory it's you know like like
it sounds it's small fast low latency so
I would say yes the cleaning go
recommend that you go to the office
hours of the app steam cloud you go to
go to developers.google.com /live the
clown team have office hours this is the
Android office hours so we're not going
to really answer questions on their
their product but you can go to their
office hours and ask them about it and
they'll give you some really detailed
answers not exactly that use case
Angeles they'll tell you yes but those
together I hope so yeah I'm it have a
little have a reason why Ellen
developers got google com caused us live
and then look for cloud / now imagine
any al says big tables of your friend
you put lost things on a big table we
have 6 comments on the turret oh yeah
from ow it's just been a movement why
from the google Cassandra come before
the Hangout okay they're also been
reposted in the courtyard back to the
moderator no it's got one of the
moderator who else this is a little bit
forward-looking huh it says when are you
guys going to straighten out html5 video
for Android video events do not behave
as documented methods do not respond as
documented can you make this priority i
can't i'm sure the browser team can my
question my fellow questions to him were
what version of Android are you on and
are you seeing it for example in the
full browser or in the webview and i
would say generally speaking you'll
probably see the correct functionality
in the browser first and if it's not
correct now by all means please let us
know as you guys before browser should
be about as good as chrome with the
nexus 7 it only can ship with the chrome
browser so Android web
the development ongoing is from the
chrome team I imagine that it's working
fine with chrome on Android if it's not
that I'm sure that it's a very important
to them to ensure that it is soon chrome
is updated outside of the Android cycles
so you can get an update for it at any
point and file bugs and firebugs
feedback actually that's very good point
if you are using the latest version of
Chrome for Android and you're seeing
this issue please do father bug for
using a previous variant of Android then
unfortunately you have to wait for your
firmware update until I guess twice
cream sandwich and then you can install
but okay yeah yeah in terms of in terms
of development priorities going forward
definitely at chrome on Android is where
the activity is and the the pre Chrome
Android browser although also webkit
browser is not going to get as much
attention I've heard the crime is
shipping on one of the new motorola
devices as part of the Google Apps suite
so what have you got that from you seen
any much protein out the other day yeah
there it that seems like quite an
interesting thing to see happened does
that mean that future devices are going
to have its a future statement I know
you guys can't comment but you
interesting thing I don't know where we
other manufacturers launch jamming
devices what does that be replacing
there anybody home oh no you do when
your knowing they directly Nexus they
didn't kill the default web browser
symptom jelly bean yeah a nexus 7 was
the first device to bikram oh yeah
that's because it was an upgrade for
Nexus not a yeah like so yeah sorry
Nexus 7 you know the first time out of
the box we could do that but you don't
want to remove an app from users fine
just they still not great i mean i'll be
pretty bad experience just a little your
bookmarks and everything well but it can
add the google chrome lot of a monday
plaza but where the new gloves that's
what they did yeah they add is chrome
for android still in beta or is it moved
to a production within
ah let me see menu was not bad but it's
a help chase you to the web it's nice to
cry out there's no I photos out better
all right it's called cram for mobile it
doesn't say it's very good oh god yeah
yeah there's nothing that suggests this
Peter cool okay yes if it's very good
next question did you read that question
up next month in the next quest in the
moderator yes date picker dialog
displays correctly in ICS if android
theme is set to android theme light but
if it is set to android style / theme no
title bar date picker dialog displays as
if in the previous android versions i am
using dialogue fragment and sport light
that's not there's not really a question
there that sounds like it's working as
intended to me because things got light
if you're running on ICS shipped alias
to feed the holiday light so you should
expect see the holo styling the ICS
styling where is the thing that I'm from
no title bar that's a pre hollow style
so I would expect it to look pretty
hollow I'd say you need to go to theme
Doha no right no title bar to get what
you're looking for which now if if I
remember correctly and I'm sure you guys
know if you set a theme with no title
bar then you lose your hello action bar
is that right I think that yeah yeah so
so don't do that well maybe you want a
full screen gallery soon as I die laaste
right we're done of you it's about it
yeah they look for theme that holo light
doctor no title bum I believe it's that
pretty sure yeah it's just be expose
about it wanting the holo styling if
you're just implicitly getting it by
targeting theme not like before but be
explicit about it and you all get the
expected result hey excellent
I don't know if it's just that I'm a
huge fan of all over if I'm lazy but I
never said styles on my applications
what when I want the system default all
the time there's an interesting app in
one of the app review sessions that
actually had a option in the overflow
menu that allowed you to change between
holo light and holo dark that's exactly
in terested which oh that was that one
daytime ones that Reese only looks at
yeah i mean what your guys feelings on
that dude do you like to see it would
you lot not like to see it personally
like a book rears yeah i think there's a
subset of cases where it's useful but i
don't generally like too many settings
the whole just make it a setting thing
is a bit you know it's like techie
developer got type people we love it
like we love being able to twiddle all
the valves and change everything but if
you ever watch real users use your app
and look at the look of bewilderment on
the face when they see too many options
then i think it's it's a good thing to
minimize choice to very sensible default
sometimes it makes sense for widgets as
well because you don't know what kind of
cover background or wallpaper the users
going to have so it's quite nice to
theme for widgets i often choose that
the transparent ones on the darker ones
sometimes and switch it when i have a
lighter background because it looks
nicer so be aware of yeah the the
contacts the applications going to be
showing or another thing might be if you
do have a settings page consider
breaking out your settings into like the
common core settings and like an
advanced section something like that see
they're not completely overwhelming for
more casual users yeah person your
fellow settings where possible yeah yeah
you should make the right choices on
their behalf I'm sort of I've been a
believer for for a number of years that
offering an excess of configurations and
settings basically is just abdicating
your responsibility as a designer and
that the difference between a really
good system or app and a not-so-good one
is when is when the designers really
think things all the way through and
make the best decision for most
people um you know at least just like
you said an excessively flexible system
is a chaotic one and just leaves people
looking bewildered and you can you can
look to for example the major competing
desktop platforms and see which one made
the really really detailed design
decisions and thought things all the way
through to the end and which ones just
said well let's just make everything an
option we we can support 17 different
ways to shut down the system because
there's different users for each one and
it's that kind of makes nobody happy
yeah yeah and Android provides a lot of
facilities for taking that
responsibility away from the user if
you're going to be storing data in your
application make the conscious decision
whether you're storing it as cash or
data locally or data on the SD card and
let the system manage that cash I need
to scrub it if it needs to scrub it
maybe it will disappear but something
like Google+ i just checked on my tablet
is using children mixing the cash but
only about five megs of it's a SD card
data outside of that so if there if it
needs to be recovered at canada at the
Apple still work properly but what you
don't want is a little slider in the app
saying how much data you want to use as
a setting just position the data
correctly to the system can deal with it
ok we have questions I'm gonna con hit
us didn't someone say they were gonna
stomp us with a question the way it's
not state the development questions more
like on the ambulance system itself I
went a bit they wanted to see the new
version you know they got access we
started getting cherry boom and doing
the ABS eight for the Samsung program
called kiss day computer shut it down
why the update and now the device is not
really wanting to turn on any ideas how
i get a how i get back up and running oh
my gosh in your device three samsung
kies I'm the computer shut down during
the flash yeah how
and you get to the bootloader yeah can
you do volume down and power the way I
can get to download model recovery and
to the boat total so yeah I can get one
of the Miller you can connect it to
fastboot so let's be sufficient for
communication to the device it gets the
boot loader so you should be able to
just reflashing again right and now
because it came from the case so I don't
have the actual war no but you can
actually connect keys in case you'd be
able to hear hey I tried the kiss
doesn't recognize the phone oh yeah yeah
is that what it's in fast food
presentation bootloader maybe it's just
when I tell it on you know it tries to
find the device it shows this a loading
thing but doesn't actually find it and
in both know that I see it but the kids
doesn't find it you know I told a
sizable devices and it sees it that's
not the hospital you can reap it into
the poop out right yes for the festival
taken give to the boat builder but I
need the actual one another to flash it
so keys doesn't see it from fastboot
what bootloader know and you've tried
doing a factory reset erase data all
that kind of thing again because it
doesn't put up today it doesn't even
know it's because it's got some halfway
and I think the new updates so there's
nothing to it is 280 billion fastboot
yeah when I I think you know the best
thing I found I thought is to flash a
you know to go to samo babes and
download the home and then try to flash
it and hope for the risk manager for it
where I can place the engine model so
yeah that might work I've heard of that
before I mean I've heard of people using
which is a clockwork is that the loader
that clock rescue non-scientist if you
can get Android in my case should report
it if you have a chat with Samsung
support they should talk you through
that because I didn't make their
equipment to fastboot and it's what keys
talks to it using okay so I need to
practice Lane chill and a little bit
either that will google translate and
post in the forums so okay thank you so
much it's going to be a fun date yeah
I had but it happened some things hello
I probably flash every five or six times
a day I always flash from a laptop when
plugged into the power with a full
battery charge I know it's one of those
things that everybody says nobody really
takes any notice but it seemed too many
devices bricked to take the risk well
you're not the advantage of the day and
Nexus devices when you flash stuff it's
much easier to do than any other devices
yes and they're also factory image is
quite widely available for the galaxy
nexus and nexus devices from google
access yes then there's a lot of name
its variants it's basically one it's
like two commands I think them flash and
then off you go I've got the cyanogen 10
on the Galaxy Nexus and it's quite
amazing what they did good watching me
have you gotten examples and you know
they again as I said it's not like for
the geek stuff so there's a lot more
settings and it is oddly relax I can see
Sparky food cringing at the word more
settings yeah a lot more settings but
the advantages it recognizes a lot of
more ap ends you know for mobile data
and stuff like that well new mobile
companies that started hearing me about
two months ago and not have been updated
to the Android days to the Android
official OS and also you know they when
it's not the initial anymore but the
heap will stuff also is there so it's
also an advantage it also has an
interesting SMS reply thing using rich
notifications doesn't it yes it does it
shows you and then you can lessons when
you're rich notification tells you about
an SMS and you can use one of the
buttons to get a dialog box and reply to
that SMS straight away without going
into the SMS app yes and also you can
actually see since the alleged
authentication notifications you can see
the message itself which is quite nice
yeah and they Google now also which is a
very nice thing to bed okay
alright so there's no more Android death
questions no Google rapper side mixer
will give you all five minutes back in
your day can do or I've just seen
announced by Sony a competition for the
UK to develop games with a twenty-five
thousand pound prize oh so it's
apparently their lines for submission is
the end of October i'll post the link in
the in the comments for the this hangout
and thur maybe some people will be able
to write some cool games and yes we will
they come up with Rich Thompson just
quickly asked if he's still in whether
anyone knows about updates for the IO
edition Galaxy Tabs the audition Galaxy
Tabs did get onto the main update stream
at some point and Samsung just haven't
announced when they're going to roll out
the 3g updates yet they're only doing
the wifis so when they do the update to
the 3g variant as well and it's barely
that Wi-Fi the unannounced updates for
galaxy tab 2 rate is it really yeah the
galaxy if m1 doesn't get Jen even they
said it's no I already started running
the guarantee to have one jellybean up
litter Oh Ice Cream Sandwich sorry
update we're still talking about ice
cream sandwich they got to nowadays
jelly bean update the galaxy tab too
much jelly bean update you guys to have
one they announced the IC hey ICS update
for the Wi-Fi variant and none of my
galaxy tabs have been updated yet but
hopefully they'll announce one for the
rest of parents at some point what about
they are getting better at sending the
updates if you look for example on
jellybean it's been out for what about
it two months something like that and
they already have it on the galaxy s3
they're starting to pivot on the go this
way I'm really really pleased to see
that the migration from ice cream
sandwich to jelly bean i think is much
easier for the companies as well than it
was room I saw salt right jellybean
update starships and there's also the
announcement I about the PDK the
platform development kit which is
shipping to big OEMs ahead of an actual
release so that they get a chance to run
up to speed before it hits at before a
release gets out to the public yeah just
cool to see yes let's be helped yeah
anything we need to help those updates
eyeballs be shorter that's pretty easy
ok remember day between chain between a
gingerbread and Isis it was a very big
time span between
you when Google actually let it sit and
when the device is actually got it yeah
this is a massive update the far more
incremental these days all right
everyone thank you very much for tuning
in I'm here same time next week
hopefully from a studio bye guys
thankfully I